[Musique]
qui était l'
un des écosystèmes les plus intéressants
du monde avant les années 60
la zone maintenant pour le tiers
est maintenant une zone désertique où bien sûr
la biodiversité n'existe plus et la
plupart des espèces  ont disparu
[Musique]
l'eau des deux rivières
a été prélevée par
des travaux d'ingénierie générale des fuites de construction des
canaux de construction qui ont bien sûr
aussi
changé la morphologie de la zone
[Musique]
quand vous avez une sorte de
pompage qui est si extrême le niveau
de la  le lac a diminué de 17
[Musique]
mètres
[Musique] [
Musique]
aussi des oiseaux et de nombreuses autres espèces d'
animaux
en raison de la dépersonnalisation du
lac mais pas seulement l'augmentation
du désert a créé
les tempêtes de soleil celles-ci bien sûr créent
un climat et et une situation
cela ne permet pas aux espèces
vivant dans la région de continuer à
[Musique]
survivre
[Musique] [
Musique]
il y a eu une augmentation de la pauvreté en raison
du manque d'accès à l'eau et de la sécurité de l'eau c'était
une catastrophe économique
[Musique]
nous savons que  les pesticides et les engrais
s'infiltrent dans le sous-sol
puis atteignent les aquifères les
ressources en eau souterraine
et bien sur l'eau potable c'est principalement
tiré des richesses qui sont pompées
dans ces aquifères
[Musique]
au kazakhstan le niveau des lacs a
augmenté
et une partie de la  les espèces sont de retour
mais en même temps ces barrages
ne permettent pas à l'écoulement de l'eau
d'atteindre la partie sud de la rlc
[Musique]
les deux rivières la sirdaria et l'
amudaria
qui prennent leur source dans l'
hindukushi et la pamira
avant  pour atteindre l'ouzbékistan et le
kazakhstan
ils passent par l'afghanistan le kirghizistan
et le tadjikistan le problème est bien plus
que seulement l'ouzbékistan et le kazakhstan la
gestion de l'eau
c'est vraiment une coordination et une
coopération régionale pour la gestion
des eaux transfrontalières de la région
sans une réelle gestion
et gouvernance durable
de  ressources en eau et en particulier les
protections des glaciers en regardant
l'impact que le changement climatique
certainement il n'y
aura pas beaucoup d'avenir pour le rlc
dans les 100 prochaines années
vous